I am honored to be the host of the ass
doc Live program where each and every
Friday what do you mean no we're the
host tests you're not the host I'm the
host this yes thank you doc
I am honored to be the hostess of the
eye stock live show where each and every
week we bring to you information
that can be used to change lives your
life the life of your loved ones the
lives of those in your community and
these are things that you can do on your
own you do not have to have a
prescription you do not have to
well okay I can't say that FDA we
prevents me from being able to say
specific things but I love the fact that
we still have our freedoms where we can
make choice and be our own authority
and in this program if you are here live
with us
make sure that you have that chat option
open so you can see all the helpful and
useful information that my co-hosts will
be posting in there and my co-hosts that
I have with me today are nasima Omar
Roselyn Sanchez Heather Bowen and Dr
Judy Reynolds and we're here as a
service
so we want to make sure people have the
resources available in order to make
wise decisions on what they can do more
naturally in their health to get away
from or stay away from the things that
are chemical in nature that the body
wasn't made from so we're giving the
body what it needs to be able to thrive
not just survive so it is a new meeting
address I glad that those of you who are
on with us found us so welcome welcome
now the doctor that we host each and
every week he has over a hundred
Publications and medical journals and
books and
not just medical journals but
there's so many places that share
information Dr Wallach has been
published that it adds more and more
credibility to the information that we
are sharing with you today
there's a lot of misinformation out
there folks
and really
check
the credentials of the information that
you're looking at
not everything that you see on a square
that boasts the positives and negatives
of something are complete I'm not saying
that they're all wrong but they're not
all complete so we want to make sure
that we're giving information that is
more complete and it's nature so that it
is of best use to you
now if you are invited to this program
by somebody specific please get back
with that person that invited you to
this program they took the time
and valued you as an individual to share
this information with you probably
because it's been pretty life-changing
for them and we invite you to feel the
difference as well
now as I mentioned Dr Wallach Dr Joel
Wallach he has a Bachelor of Science in
agriculture he is a vet a doctor of
veterinarian medicine who has done
research around the world it's not just
classroom experience that it takes to a
little clinic in some small Missouri
Town this is information that has been
done or has been collected around the
world with his research and in zoos
around the world not just with domestic
animals but
animals of all shapes sizes blood types
all just everything and he
like most scientists have taken this
information from animals and he has done
some extensive work in comparing it with
that of humans
like over thirty thousand autopsies
folks do you know how many data points
they look at in a single autopsy and
then he's done some comparative
pathology and really looked at how the
animal world relates to the human world
and I'm excited that through his books
and through his availability we can
bring that information to you so that
you also can make wise decisions in
helping yourself obtain Optimal Health
now Dr Joel Wallach welcome to ask doc
daily
well thank you so much
is this F Scott Taylor or ask live oh
this is our stock live oh my goodness
books
and for those of you who don't know Dr
Wallach and I also have a program called
askdoc daily
that we do daily so I suggest to take
some memory effects three times a day
along with your other nutrients
memory FX got it I've already got
de-stressed so we've got that too twice
a day
okay I'm smart
thank you so much for the kind
introduction and of course
um my thesis
on twenty thousand autopsy it says in
the Smithsonian Institute as a National
Treasure I'm very very proud of that
and
um and because it showed that there were
no gently transmitted diseases now
that's very profound when you think
about it there are no genetically
transmitted diseases there are no
autoimmune diseases and
um the thesis brand new in the box
was published as a textbook by WB
Saunders the biggest medical textbook
publishing house that we only sell for
twenty five thousand dollars each I
don't expect everybody to do that but we
do have a summary of that thesis it's
called epigenetics the death of a
genetic theory of disease transmission
um okay and uh epigenetics really really
goes through so many things there you go
you got it and
um then to to kind of bring that to the
street if you will to where everybody
can utilize this information
um one of the books that was written
some years ago is called prepare
okay now that's a picture of me when I
was in the military I was in military
for 27 years okay uh I was a pretty bad
boy when I was in the military
I went all over the world
um for the U.S government I probably
went to uh at least 25 different
countries and it was a battle battle
fronts
in every country and in their Wars even
though we weren't maybe in the war they
sent me there to deal with things and so
uh in this book prepare there's 14
chapters and of course the subtitle is a
prepper survival Bible a prepper
survival Bible this talks not only about
how to survive you know a shooting war
that kind of thing but also how to
survive a war against the environment a
war against bad food and so forth all
this is in here and I urge everybody to
get this as a gift for the people they
love okay prepare because this
information okay can add 25 to 50 Health
years of your life and save you from
very bad experiences now with that said
Dr Judy was holding up her version of
prepare and I don't know if you saw it
she's got tabs all over the place
because she's gone through the book and
I think this is a highlighter and pencil
and writes and then in the margins yeah
and Judy did you did you find things
useful you know on a day-to-day basis
absolutely and here's something else I
discovered Dr Wallach I already had this
book
God Bless America yep so this was a
previous version
because I had already highlighted this
one and gone through it and then when I
started going through the other one it
was like oh this looks familiar so I
have them both I thank you yeah and of
course
um information is power information is
power and also
um let's see here it's one of those
things where the book Hell's Kitchen
tells you why we're in trouble the book
Hell's Kitchen tells you why we're in
trouble okay it goes through the
transition from wood stoves and coal
stoves okay and wood furnaces and cold
furnaces and fireplaces and that sort of
stuff and just fire pits over the
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years we use wood and coal to fuel to
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 on curl Street in New
York City and the bluff we're looking
the construction of Brooklyn Bridge and
we switched over to electricity
now for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years we use wood ashes and
coal ashes as fertilizer in our Gardens
and also as a supplement okay
nutritional supplement and wood ashes
and coal ashes are 95 percent
minerals that are left when you burn the
carbon and the fuel and two or three
percent
um carbon okay now once we went to
electricity that was all gone this is a
huge transition a huge transition taking
our source of vitamin mineral
supplements for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years going away and it
gets worse because when they switch to
hydroelectric plants instead of just
using the the windmills which had
limited capacity to make electricity
they came up with the idea of the
hydroelectric dams and everybody was so
excited because it stopped the flooding
they didn't have the spring floods
anymore well the spring floods would
bring the silts from the mountains okay
and flood the Farms and the cities and
so forth and then
um after a couple of weeks or a month or
so all the water would recede and leave
all that silt okay in the fields and the
farmers would Plow That silt back into
the fields renew the fields every year
with those minerals that the plants had
sucked out the previous year okay during
the plant's growth
well by 1930 we were in trouble by 1930
we were in big doo-doo okay even the
United States Senate came out with U.S
Senate document 264 1936 and said our
American Farm saws no longer have
sufficient minerals in the soil to
support healthy and long life for humans
the United States said that in 1936 and
that's when they came out with confirm
excuse me
um commercial fertilizer prior to that
they were using manure and compost and
all this kind of stuff and also you know
using the silt from the spring floods
and then once that was all gone suddenly
now they had to come out with a
commercial fertilizer because nothing
would grow without something and so and
plants only need three minerals plants
only need three minerals to grow and
make good seeds for the Next Generation
we need sixty six zero minerals and of
course one of the things that I'm really
really excited about of course is our
rebound and people say why are you
talking so much about rebound well
rebound has 100 nutrients in it 75
minerals 75 minerals and 25 vitamins
amino acids we have the canister with
powder 36 servings we have the box with
30 sticks we have the cans 12 ounce cans
and the only sort of issue I have with
the cans which I drink two of a day
um I popped the tops on them at night
before I go to sleep put them in the
refrigerator so they off gas the
carbonation and so they said why don't
you just get rid of the carbonation well
because Red Bull is carbonated and
they're the biggest
carbonation okay which is it's hazardous
but people like it just like alcohol can
be potentially hazardous but people like
it okay so we we keep the the
um carbonation in the cans but I I off
gas it before I drink them you know pop
them and put them in the refrigerator I
drink them the next day
um but um you think about it Red Bull
has one mineral repeat that Red Bull has
one mineral magnesium we have 75
minerals
that's a big difference 75 versus one
now why did one of the the greatest
Fitness gurus okay Bruce Lee why did he
die 32
I spent two weeks
going through all his interviews with
newspapers and magazines and radios and
TVs I mean I was working 20 to 24 hours
a day for two weeks okay because when he
died in 1973 at age 32 he died at age 32
he died at age 32.
um the doctors said we don't know why he
died okay and then
um let's see here 49 years later just a
couple of months ago they came out and
said the doctor said we finally figured
out why Bruce Lee died he died of
drinking too much water well I knew that
was junk and so that's why I spent the
two weeks going through all his
interviews but that was a question that
people asked what did you eat what'd you
avoid and all this kind of stuff what
did you supplement with the only
supplement he took was magnesium I'm
assuming he had muscle cramps so he took
magnesium which would leave muscle
cramps and that's why when Red Bull came
out they only put magnesium in the Red
Bull because they were they were
following Bruce Lee's
um which I say his legacy because he was
considered the fitness Guru in the world
okay now now comes there's a new Bull in
town okay there's a new Bull in town and
there's three CDs in here one many of
you have heard before
um uh dead athletes don't lie it's kind
of like Dead Doctors Don't Lie right and
then the second one many of you have
heard but not everybody is
um exercise was helenation of suicide
and then the third CT in there many
people have not heard okay it was a
lecture I gave up in Canada and 50 of
the people in the audience were Canadian
fifty percent of people are married like
2 000 people in there and this third CD
okay what kills billionaires goes into
Athletics as well as rich people's
Lifestyles and habits okay now I want
everybody
when they get this set okay they're
available now you can go to
www.drjwalk.com
www.drjwalk.com and get the set they're
all done ready to go
and
um the the one that I want you to listen
to First is what what kills billionaires
according to
the US government the life expectancy of
billionaires in America is 66.7
billionaires life expectancy and and
Rebecca and I have long discussions
about this you know is there information
accurate blah blah blah do they conclude
all age groups and and so forth is as
worldwide is this just America and so
forth so we're kind of looking into that
but this is what it said okay you can
have Siri okay you know what is uh life
expectancy of billionaires American
they'll say Siri says 66.7 okay and so
that's what Siri says now you have to
depreciate
that billionaires can afford the best
medicine they can afford the best
doctors they can afford the best surgery
they can afford the best food they can
afford the best everything the best
coaches the best memberships in fitness
centers and and um uh gymnasiums and so
forth so why would they have a lower
life expectancy than the general
population
well that's because when you're a
billionaire you get to do what you want
and when they go out to eat they can
spend 200 and many of them do they'll
spend 200 per meal for each person and
their party okay
and so it's one of those things where
you know I don't have to supplement I
eat well they have this fallacy that you
can you know that old
um
you know which they say
um thing uh eat well you get everything
you need and then they came out with the
the four food groups even the even you
ask the doctor what about this for a
food group thing well if you eat four
food groups you're gonna be guaranteed
to get everything you need that's not
true
okay well what about the seven food
group pyramid that's not true either
okay okay and so uh what's going on uh
with the
um let's see here all these various
diets they have all right the low
calorie diet and then
um
let's see here
um what what's some of your favorite
diets um Rebecca that the the
billionaires use okay
well I mean a lot of them are going
vegan or vegetarian
um
okay so why why is it giving away vital
nutrients yeah so why why is a vegan or
vegetarian diet not good if you're not
supplementing with the 90 essential
nutrients how many minerals can a plant
make none
okay plants cannot make on its own okay
now do nutritional minerals occur in a
uniform blanket around the crust of the
earth no
they occur in veins like gold and silver
and so if you're only supplementing with
one mineral because you're drinking a
Red Bull you're only supplementing with
magnesium you're drinking Red Bull which
is primarily sugar and caffeine okay
because it's an energy drink okay it was
not meant to be a nutritional
supplement well our our rebound is an
energy drink and a nutritional
supplement it has a hundred nutrients
that 75 minerals Red Bull has one
75 minerals versus one we have 25
vitamins amino acids versus four that's
in Red Bull okay plus we have like 30
percent less sugar and 75 I think it is
less caffeine okay because we're we're
depending on the nutrients for energy
and and resistance to disease and all
this kind of stuff and you know I drink
my rebound during the day but I still
take my healthy brain and heart pack
which has 215 nutrients the core is
still the 90. I take two servings a day
of the healthy and heart pack and then I
drink my rebound and so I'm getting the
90 essential nutrients like three and
four times a day
okay I'm 83 years old going on 84 and
people freak out because you know they
say well like your energy doesn't look
like you're how many prescription drugs
are young none and I was on prescription
antibiotics for three days my whole life
that's it
um and so when you look at the the CD or
not look at it but listen to the CD
uh what kills billionaires it goes into
their their food choices their lifestyle
choices okay uh their supplement choices
and so forth why they have such a low
um life expectancy according to those
surveys okay government surveys now it's
one of those things that
um this information in that CD goes into
athletes
because you know and when you look at it
uh let's see here some of these people
that are famous uh when you look at
um let's see here uh Jim fix okay he
wrote the first major books for the
public on the the value of exercise and
he died of 56 of a heart attack while he
was running a marathon right in the
middle of the marathon he drops dead at
age 56 from a heart attack
and then what about Steve Jobs the guy
who came up with apple he was a
vegetarian a vegan that's why he named
his company Apple okay and apple a day
keeps a doctor away right and he dies at
52 from pancreatic cancer
and both those guys
were billionaires
okay so what's going on here okay well
they they chose poorly you've heard that
before they chose poorly okay and
it doesn't matter if you're famous if
you choose poorly you're gonna die young
okay could die suddenly you could you
know like and Jim fix or you could be
like Steve Jobs and die miserably for
after a period of months or years with a
terrible abdominal cancer okay
and so this is something I want
everybody to listen to it'll blow your
mind if if this I I cannot believe that
this CD what kills billionaires won't
add 25 to 50 Health years of your life
if you do everything that's in there
because it's designed to talk to
billionaires okay but it was my speech
that I gave in Canada and you can hear
me because I'm describing the faces in
the audience because when I'm saying
these things these people are getting
petrified their mouths are dropping open
their eyes are going from a normal human
eye size to like five times the human
size their eyes are just going crazy
because of the information I'm passing
on to them they've never heard before
and so everybody needs to listen at
least twice a week bury it twice a day
to what kills billionaires okay can buy
that CD by itself or better yet get the
set there's a new Bull in town and I
love the fact that I'm getting four
meals a day you know between my another
random heart pack twice and my Rebound
with 100 nutrients okay rebound has 100
nutrients in it I'm having that twice a
day and I'm having the um another heart
pack of 215 nutrients in it twice a day
and I'm avoiding all the bad stuff so
you know I'm in pretty good shape for an
83 year old guy going in 84. okay
I'm like a rock I can you know do more
than most people who are in their teens
and 20s and 30s and 40s and 50s and so
you know try working
28 hours a day seven days a week oh no
let me take that back 28 hours a day 18
hours a week
no 18 days a week
okay okay so with that I'm going to turn
it back over uh let's see here am I hit
that point yet uh yeah I'm going to turn
this back over to Rebecca and see if you
want to ask me any questions on anything
or if we're going to go to to callers
yeah so Dr well like I want to and I
thank you very much for bringing
something up because there's been many
times where people have said well Dr
Wallach pushes rebounds so much why do I
have to take Tangy Tangerine
okay well Tangy Tangerine of course
um it's kind of like the pre-rebound
okay it's one of those things we had to
come up with a supplement that had all
these nutrients in it okay if how many
supplements in the market have 75
minerals in there and 25 vitamins we're
the only ones okay and and so your busy
day oh gosh I forgot to bring my Rebound
with me okay well if you took your your
health brand and hard pack which has 215
nutrients in it the core is still the
90. okay
and you think of all the famous athletes
okay whether they're
um ladies like um let's see uh we we got
um our girl who became a
um All-American okay Kelly Herron Kelly
Herron yes yeah yeah she was all broken
down and she was you know her early 20s
I think she was like about 21 uh she was
playing basketball for the University of
Tennessee at
um uh in in Tennessee and she came to
one of my meetings in Tennessee and she
was a mess and um I put her on the same
program and we put um uh our male
basketball players on okay and
um the next season she became uh one of
the few women all-americans
okay and this gals
um almost seven foot tall she just short
a seven foot tall okay but she was
missing the nutrients so just being tall
isn't enough to play basketball okay
uh you have to have
um stamina you have to have agility you
have to have accuracy you have to have
good Vision you have to have stamina all
this kind of stuff
and
um this is why so many athletes of every
sport boxing uh the real deal okay
Evander Holyfield
um this is why we have things going on
um in in the black community this is the
next month is Black History Month okay
and so I've been invited to the you know
one of the speakers because I've in my
whole life I've been working with the
black community I grew up in a farm all
of our employees in the farm were black
okay and I I my dad was a Golden Gloves
um uh All-American okay a boxer boxing
if you didn't know folks that's boxing
yeah a boxer yeah yeah and so he was
world champion
um Golden Gloves boxer and so I was
always in the gyms I was like two years
old now I'm in the gymnasiums you know
giving water to the boxers in their
Corner that sort of stuff but 99 of the
boxers I was dealing with were from the
black community and so I learned
a lot
um you know why was it that the slaves
live longer than the plantation owners
I'm gonna repeat that why is it that the
plantation owners died before the slaves
died okay huh well the plantation owners
wanted to be like Europeans and they
were eating European food
whereas the slaves they didn't have
access they couldn't afford European
food so they're eating what they grew in
their Gardens but they're doing
something else that the
the plantation owners weren't doing they
were eating wood ashes they were putting
them in their Gardens to grow their
carrots and their potatoes and their
beans and and onions and so forth and um
they were also putting it in their food
as a spice because they couldn't afford
the spices at the plantation so it
wasn't unusual for the plantation owners
to die in their 40s 50s and 60s were the
the slaves were living to be 70 80 90
100 110 120 and that's sort of getting
you know the the stories of these
um
these slaves in the plantations you know
Uncle Remus who would be like 112 115
sort of thing uh why it wasn't a genetic
thing it's because they were getting the
metals because they're using the wood
ashes and the breakfast lunch and dinner
and snacks okay whereas the plantation
owners we're not doing that and all this
is in the book
let's see here black Gene lies because
they had so many movie actors a black
um from the black community I have so
many uh people who are in uh the
churches who are pastors I have so many
people who are
um uh politicians in the black community
okay and they're coming to me and asking
me about this I said no there are no
genetic diseases and black folks white
folks yellow folks red folks there are
no genetic diseases and that's why my
thesis
okay five thousand Pages twenty thousand
autopsies is in the Smithsonian
institute's National Treasure and sells
new for twenty five thousand dollars
okay and so
um because I showed there were no
exactly transferences and there are no
autoimmune diseases doctors made that
stuff up when they didn't know the
answers they didn't want to admit
ignorance and so they just said well
it's your body attacking itself no no no
well what if I have five generations of
people in my family with diabetes Well
that's because they all live in the same
county and eat the same way well
there you go and so again nutritional
minerals are not occur in uniform black
around the custody Earth they occur in
veins so
um I really really really whether you're
white or black put the book down put it
down go ahead and put it down because
whenever you hold it in front of your
face it muffles your voice oh okay thank
you thank you oh okay so anyway I want
everybody to get a hold of those books
and and spend time even if you're only
reading a couple of paragraphs And
discussing them with your family one one
hour a week or something like that on a
Tuesday night or something when nothing
else is going on
all right and then give them a little
homework say read this chapter and then
let's all discuss it next week and kind
of thing and these books can add so much
information
to add so many
months and years to your life and the
quality of your life will go way up and
then again don't forget this one what
kills billionaires I mean I was so
excited listen to that again I had
forgotten I had forgotten okay that I
actually had um let me get this right
yeah I had forgotten
that I had um
written
books I had done that CD
what kills billionaires up in Canada
okay I don't know 10 12 years ago
whatever it was
oh my gosh and I went back and I
listened to that again the other day
it just blows your mind the information
I put in there okay the dispels the myth
about genetics dispel is a myth about
being rich is enough to get to Elizabeth
100 no being rich can be a negative if
you're just saying well I'm rich I can
do whatever I want okay no there's
gravity you can't do whatever you want
there's a need for 90 essential
nutrients it goes into great detail
research
not only my research but other people's
research all the stuff that's been done
to show how much we need those 90
essential nutrients what kills
billionaires oh my gosh okay well and my
whole purpose for bringing this up Dr
Wallach is rebound is not a replacement
for the 90 essential nutrients it is not
a replacement for the healthy body pack
that includes the Beyond Tangy Tangerine
the Osteo effects and the EFA plus I
like the brain and heart pack which you
recommend often but when we're looking
at making sure that our body gets
exactly what it needs
it's not being reliant on rebound
rebound is an extra it's that secret
sauce especially for those that are very
active in sports Athletics working out
Rebecca what are she what why did we
invent the secret sauces I mean when you
have the Healthy Start pack we got the
healthy Bone and Joint pack but we have
um the health Iran and heart attack why
do we have the secret sauces
well they're they're a response to help
correct
the deficiency that has already happened
for a specific disease for specific
conditions yes okay we have we have
secret sauces for diabetes we have
secret sauces or high blood pressure we
have secret sauces for arthritis we have
secret sauces or asthma we have secret
sauces for Alzheimer's disease MS uh we
have secret sauces for Parkinson's
Disease we have secret sauces for
infertility we have secret sauces for Ed
we have secret sauces okay for over 600
different conditions I don't think you
left anything out
laughs
you're pretty thorough Dr Wallach okay
there's another one here why did we come
up with it's all in your head the book
of the CD that you and I did okay why
did we come up with this on your head
there's 37 different diseases you can
get 37 different diseases 37 different
diseases you can get okay we have
osteoporosis of the skull and doctors
don't even get taught in medical school
that you can get osteoporosis in the
skull they have no no conclusion I'll
tell you one of my favorite ones is you
know when men are getting up three five
eight ten times a night to urinate
doctors say oh you have a prostate
problem let's do a biopsy they do biopsy
okay you don't have cancer okay but
let's watch it and you know here take
some stuff and we'll see if we can make
your prostate gland happy blah blah blah
but what about women women also get up
three five eight ten times a night to
your name they don't have prostate
glands women don't have prostate glands
so what's the problem and so that's when
I started looking into what was going on
here and what's going on when you're
getting up at night three five eight ten
times a night it's because you're a
Scholars using the spinal cord and the
spinal cord is telling your urinary
bladder to urinate whether you're a male
or a female
and so that got me looking into that got
me looking into the osteoporosis of the
skull and the 37 different diseases you
can get you know doctors will say well
yeah my brother he's a dentist okay and
you have receding gums I'm going to
referred to my denim my brother who's a
dentist oh I have a brother whose ear
nose and throat doctor and you have a
hearing problem and and balance problems
I'm going to send you my to my brother
who is a okay and here throws a note dog
or he'll give you a hearing aid and a
walker and so forth but this is because
the skull is squeezing
the 12 pairs of cranial nerves okay
there's 37 different diseases you can
get
when you have osteoporosis uh on the
skull I'll quickly run through them if I
may Becca okay yeah and I'm I'm holding
up here what it looks like this is what
the brain is supposed to look like this
white line that's the skull
see how there's some air in there and
you can see the definition of the brain
and then whenever the skull thickens
with the osteoporosis of the skull it
squeezes everything and then you wonder
well why can't I think clearly why are
things just not working within the body
well yeah and that's on page six that's
on page six of the book it's on your
head
it's on page six of the book it's on
your head you see those two pictures
very good okay when the first cranial
nerves okay
um the olfactory nerve is being squeezed
um you get lost a sense of smell second
cranial nerve being squeezed optic nerve
you get
um gradual loss of vision the doctor say
well you're getting old you're losing
your vision we've got to do this
operation this operation and so on you
have Ona optic nervantrophy also the
optic nerve artery and optic nerve vein
uh cranial nerve number three gets
squeezed you get ptosis and your pupil
does not respond to uh light okay and
doctors want to do surgery there and
then the fourth cranial nerve getting a
squeeze you get double vision fifth
trial nerve again trigeminal neuralgia I
mean you this is one of the most painful
headaches there is a trigeminal
neurology because the fifth renal nerve
is being squeezed by the skull double
Visions when you have your six train
there being squeezed Bell's palsy and
one side of your face groups ask a
doctor what causes Bell's palsy and they
they don't know but it's caused by your
skull squeezing the seventh cranial
nerve it could be one-sided time or both
sides okay tonight is ringing in the
ears deafness vertigo dizziness it's
your skull squeezing the eighth green
nerve and then the ninth real nerve
being squeezed you lose your gag reflex
your ability to swallow easily your
voice changes you lose your sense of
taste and then 10th grade under being
squeezed you get gastropriate I mean
stomach pain that'll bring you to your
knees and doctor said oh you have a
stomach ulcer you also have hiccups has
a branches that tense pill nerve is
being a squeeze and it goes to your
diaphragm and then afib atrial
fibrillation has nothing to do with your
heart but it gives it squeezes the the
nerves going to your heart and that
actually
um causes your heart to beat irregularly
and your doctors want to anesthetize you
take your heart out of your chest and
give you an ablation which is putting a
hot branding on your heart and killing
part of your heart muscle don't do that
has the highest death rate of any
medical procedure and then a crown nerve
number 11 when it's getting squeezed you
can't lift your arms above your head
because it controls the trapezius
muscles and then when the 12th real
nerve gets squeezed you get atrophy of
the tongue uh the speech and when so
when you have your ninth cranial nerve
and your 12th trailer being squeezed you
can't communicate and then when your
spinal cord is being squeezed there's 17
of those 37 different diseases that
occur because your spinal support is
being squeezed by your skull and so
doctors had no earthly idea about that
getting up at night three five eight ten
times a night whether you're a girl or
boy doesn't matter it's just it doesn't
matter age okay you're going to have um
getting up at night to urinate so many
times
and so we've renamed this uh wallach's
fibrosis because the spinal cord is
being squeezed because you have
osteoporosis of the skull okay wallic
fibrosis is causing all that and so
these are things all of these 37
different diseases can go away when you
deal with the osteoporosis of the skull
and I mean Rebecca you've been working
with me for a long time and you know
you're a health coach and you've seen so
many of these issues that we're talking
about here have you seen any of them get
better
um well it started with me
so yeah I I've seen it I've felt it
um and I'm just one of many that I've
worked with and you've experienced it
and I've experienced it firsthand
that's why I'm here today Dr Wallach
I wouldn't do anything I don't believe
in
there's been a lot of things that I've
started
but when I find that I can't believe in
it I can't stand behind it I don't
so that's that's why I'm here today Dr
Wallach
and we appreciate you because you are
one of God's angels you're definitely uh
plow into this and you are I I love it
the fact that you are a detective and
you are going to make sure that
everything is right when you pass on
information you have made triple sure
that everything is right and so I'm very
very proud of you for that and that's
why he says he's proud but I frustrated
people when he and I are going through
and talking about different conditions
and he's bringing up things Siri
it it gives the results I'm like okay
doc what year was that
what are the date ranges that those
dates are that number's pulled from
who's reporting it
because I want all of those facts I
don't want to just what somebody
programmed in for Siri to tell him or
tell us
we want to make sure that we are using
reputable information
to pass along
it's like I'm a fact Checker checker
I am into statistics I'm a numbers
person I love charts
so I want to make sure that when I'm
looking at something
it makes sense and the information has
not been scrubbed to present somebody's
narrative yeah well that's why we're
we're working on what kills billionaires
right now okay we're trying to really
really get into why is it that
billionaires have a rough time they have
all the money in the world they can
afford the best doctors they can afford
the best memberships in in gymnasiums
and coaches and all that kind of stuff
they can eat the best food they get the
best medication they go anywhere in the
world for the treatment for something
and yet
as a group they don't live as long
according to
you know what's being said right now by
the medical groups
um okay uh and Siri okay and then the
series says that billionaires in America
their life expectancy up until a couple
of days ago was 66.7 now it's 66. okay
it's dropping okay they're dying younger
but billionaires why is that okay well
they can get the best food they can get
the best medicine they belong the best
gyms they get the best personal coaches
and trainers what is the problem here
well that's because they get on the
newest thing oh I'm going to be on the
four food group diet I don't need to
take vitamins and Mills because I'm on
the four food group diet I don't need to
take vitamins and minerals because I
exercise oh I'm going to
um you know do the
um uh low-fat diet I'm going to do the
um
carbohydrates diet I'm going to do this
diet that's that's the way billionaires
work okay and so so it's one of those
things where they do it to themselves
because
when you when you re when you listen to
that CD what kills billionaires we go
into the research of why everybody
regardless of what that program you
choose you better be taking the 90
essential nutrients because nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform blank
around the coast of the Earth and the
beginning of our life expectancy and our
health demise started when we switched
from what is fuel to electricity
and when we went to hydroelectric dams
of human health just did a downward
spiral and it all comes down to when we
cut out our mineral source and our food
plants only need three minerals we need
60.
so you can have the most beautiful
looking stuff in their organic argentius
means no chemicals organic doesn't mean
anything about the nutritional value of
the food
organic doesn't mean anything about the
nutritional value of the food our Cactus
means no chemicals
and people think oh it's organic they
think it's more nutritious no
yeah definitely not more nutritious for
sure I mean yes it's less toxic
but not more nutritious
there you go so you need to follow both
pads you want less toxicity you want
more nutrition
definitely because epigenetics
what has that done that's proven that
what we put in our mouths what we have
in our environment makes
how our body works
positive and negative
and it's the death of the genetic theory
of disease transmission
so not the new one on the Block but you
know it's just recently I've been
showing this to people I've kind of been
so busy with other things I really
haven't
um what should I say Advanced this book
to the point where it really can help so
many people 14 chapters okay okay the
prepper survival Bible is the prepper
survival Bible it goes into the
nutrition goes into the toxicity goes in
exercise goes into pollution I mean
we're talking about the whole thing and
this is a picture of me this is my
picture out in the field uh on a battle
field okay I did this for 27 years
okay I'm uh and of course I Was A Boy
Scout I was an eagle scout and that's
why they Advanced me so much because I
had so many merit badges in first aid
and everything like that and I knew more
than their field Medics did and say
Eagle Scout and art of the arrow a Boy
Scout and of course what is the motto of
the Boy Scouts Rebecca
be prepared ask me about 4-H and I can
tell you
be prepared be prepared that's about all
the boys because be prepared so that's
why I named this book
prepare prepare awesome
well Dr Wallach let's get to some
questions that we have before we take
our break here in 15 minutes
and we have somebody the first question
that came up in the chat and for those
of you who are on with us live you can
write your questions in the chat you can
raise your virtual hand don't do this
but raise your virtual hand and I'll see
your hand here in on my screen and we'll
be coming to those with their hands up
in the order that they re were raised
but the first question that came up Dr
Wallach in the chat is what products can
a pregnant 24 year old take to fight GBS
which is Group B strep so they can avoid
and require antibiotics when the baby is
born
okay
well I would be doing
um let's see I have to check it and
double check it but I would think
colloidal silver okay I would be
thinking colloidal silver I'll have to
check that out
but um think about that uh this is our
antibiotics of the times for thousands
of years thousands of years before
penicillin came along in 1936 okay and
when penicillin came along doctors loved
penicillin because
you need a prescription you had to pay
for an office call and all this kind of
stuff and so doctors gravitated to the
penicillin the penicillin was only good
against gram-positive bacteria you know
like staphylococcus and streptococcus
that's that's it
whereas colloidal silver is good against
everything including the coveted virus
and so I do the
alcohol silver okay I do young Jody's
colloidal silver I do two droppers fell
under my tongue 30 minutes before each
meal uh two droppers fell out of my
tongue 30 minutes for bedtime
and so that's why you know I I meet so
many people and they're shaking hands
and they come and they visit me and they
come see me and they don't wear their
masks and all this kind of stuff and so
they're you know they're not thinking
straight and so I have to protect myself
so I'm doing the colloidal silver and
I've never heard of any birth defect
being caused by women using colloidal
silver I've never heard of any
um women losing a pregnancy you know
having a a loss of a pregnancy because
of using colloidal silver but I would
start out low you know use just a few
drops of colloidal silver under the
tongue
um and that's going to help you fend off
bugs including
um covid
19 which is virus a few drops or dropper
fulls Dr Wallace I start out with the
future jobs give me a couple of weeks to
do some research and everything like
that but I have never seen anything
where there's any warnings about do not
use during pregnancy or this has caused
a
spontaneous abortion of a pregnancy or
something like that I've never never
read or seen or heard anything like that
but you know let me double check it out
okay
yes absolutely and they we have a couple
other things that
um can be used for that condition but
not while pregnant so we want to make
sure that we are giving information that
is is not misleading that's not going to
have any type of it always you want your
bone marrow to be happy and healthy and
so this is why you need the MSM okay
because MSM helps you build your bone
marrow your bone marrow makes white
blood cells which is your your infantry
right and he goes and kills viruses
bacteria fungus and yeast and then of
course the collagen peptides that also
helps you with your bone marrow your
white blood cells your stem cells to
make antibodies and red blood cells and
platelets and all that kind of stuff and
so uh you know people say well I eat
well but are you getting these 90
essential nutrients that's going to make
your bone marrow
as effective as it can be in making all
the things that are going to protect you
against the bugs you know white blood
cells and you know there's so many
people including you I mean you're the
sort of anti
um vaccination person uh because you're
you know you see all these people that
are they're pointing to their fingers
saying well if they died because they
were vaccinated okay okay well
um but still up in the air whether
that's true or not but there's still
there is a correlation okay and I don't
know if it's just numbers or what's
going on but we'll find out
and it's one of those things where
um you do have to pay attention to what
you're eating stay away from the bad
stuff maximize abortion no fried foods
no processed meat so oils no gluten so
we put around notes no no buckwheat no
sugar and I used to think buckwheat was
good and they're even putting on
buckwheat labels on boxes and bags
no gluten gluten-free which is true but
buckwheat has phagopyines in it which
are worse than gluten
well and and just so people understand
you know kind of what phagopyrenes do
if you've ever experienced poison oak
poison ivy
and then you're eating that it has a
similar reaction when it comes in
contact with the digestive system if you
were to take buckwheat the plant and rub
it on your skin
I mean horses have experienced this they
get outbreaks
inflammation redness sores
so think about it that those chemicals
are going into your digestive system
so it's causing that inflammation and
damage within the digestive system as
well but like Dr Wallach said
it's gluten free
and I used to eat
luckily
for breakfast
I mean that was that was the healthy
thing to do that and oatmeal no we did
when I was a kid too
yeah and
since I've stopped
I I don't have the bloating I don't have
the pain the digestive issues
that I had for
45 years yeah well that's why I had
um
let's see here I had Tourette's Syndrome
for five years when I was a kid 20
doctors couldn't figure it out that's
because I was eating buckwheat and
gluten
for breakfast lunch and dinner as a kid
kind of like Bruce Lee
but thank goodness I figured it out when
I was nine because I started eating the
Alfalfa pellets that we gave to calves
that were fortified with vitamins and
minerals so it wasn't just the Alfalfa
but the Alfalfa didn't have any
buckwheat and it didn't have any gluten
in it but they were also fortified with
all the vitamins and minerals so I'm
getting
a you know this getting away from all
the bad stuff and doing all the good
stuff and I healed myself in three days
after five years and 20 different
doctors couldn't fix me
yeah it's amazing um no doctors can't
fix you your body can do some amazing
stuff when it's given the right stuff
well Dr wellick so let's go over kind of
a full protocol that you would recommend
for somebody who is pregnant and dealing
with a strep type bacteria right
well again
um there's choices here uh when you're
looking at external stuff again uh you
can use our colloidal silver uh you can
take it internally you can put there's
no alcohol in our colloidal silver so
you can put on an open wound okay it's
infected or before it gets infected you
can put the collateral silver and open
wound because it's just like water looks
like water tastes like water smells like
water has no alcohol in it has no
burning effect now our hand sanitizer
has alcohol in it you don't want to use
that in an open room
but also when again you want to support
your bone marrow you want to support
your immune system because your own
immune system will kill the bugs okay
from the inside and that's that's one of
the safest things one of the best things
for the embryo okay is take the 90
essential nutrients and again I urge
people to
um you know get a hold of the book
prepare it'll hold the book epigenetics
get a hold of the book Hell's Kitchen
get a hold if you're in the black
community get a hold of you know if
you're in the white Community too get a
hold of the book um black Gene lives and
so forth get a hold of the book
um and see here watch another one
um
well there's so many books Dr Wallach
the immortality
I love the fact
calm
has all your
book and the new website that is getting
ready to launch and be at the same
location we'll have bundles that you can
buy and it's like okay Dr Wallach has
these different bundles that he
recommends the trilogy of books the
quartet of books the health coach bundle
you'll be able just to click on one and
it orders them and it gives you a little
bit of a savings as well so I'm excited
to be able to offer that for sure you
can't thank you enough because we are
going to save more and more people and
of course we want America
uh and our Associates and Affiliates and
and people who we work with all over the
world
to get this information and live better
live longer pass on the information to
their families and children and their
um
their faith mates regardless of what
faith you're in okay we want you to pass
on this information and of course
this is
um one of the things that um
religion did was get people gathered
together and they could share
information okay and whenever there was
somebody who was given information by
the good Lord okay like Moses and Jesus
and uh those kinds of people and
they were they were given information
and we have a book coming out on that
one too it's called the third Testament
we're in the final stages of getting
that one published also the third
Testament and of course it gives a
highlight of the Old Testament it gives
a highlight of the New Testament
remember the Old Testament was three
thousand five hundred years ago and the
New Testament was two thousand years ago
so I figured it was about time to update
the things that the good Lord has given
us since 2000 years ago okay and so this
is not to take away from the Old
Testament doesn't have to take away from
the New Testament but this is and I've
learned that as new information comes
along you have to keep adding to the
body of information you have to keep
adding to the library okay don't take
away anything you just keep adding two
and so this book the third Testament is
going to be adding to the Old Testament
be adding to the New Testament and
um we can sell them as a bundle the Old
Testament the New Testament and the
third Testament are we going to sell
them individually yes people want and
this is
um so near and dear to my heart
um and I don't know that you see I don't
think you've seen a draft of the third
Testament yet Rebecca I don't think
you've seen a draft to that yes I have
Dr Wallach I have read it in its
entirety and I see it as being just a
continuation using today's technology to
look at the clues of the past and not so
it's not adding to it's not replacing
it's a continuation there you go and so
we're going to give the good Lord as we
do in the book all the credit and we're
just The Messengers we're not taking the
credit we're just if we're going to take
credit where credit is we're gods for
some reason has enlightened us to give
the information in a form which
everybody has access to and I'm very
very excited about that
and and so and then we have the Wallach
Revolution coming out which is something
you're involved with with the health
coaches and and this big group of people
uh including lawyers and everybody came
out with this book uh the wallet
Revolution and uh I'm excited about that
we're down in the final stages on that
one okay and yeah so we're we are on the
final stages and I'm holding up the the
old book the first edition
is the first edition the unauthorized
which is going to be the authorized
biography of Dr Joel Wallach and we have
some valuable information that we're
adding to it also in the back of the
book plus giving the
just Doc's approval on it and and his
thankfulness and gratitude for the
Citizens Community for Better Health
who who have put this together
so
um and here's another that's a great
thing we have a new we do have a new
issue of the book
um Dr Wallace click without the bad
foods we have 50 50 new pages in there
with all these new recipes that are
gluten-free
like crazy okay
yeah so well they're buying the the
current cookbook like crazy Dr Wallach
yes we don't have the new one but it's
coming and it's actually at the
Publishers now so we're it's you're
looking at the days looking at printing
in days yes for sure well Dr Wallach
it's break time I don't know about you
but I need a drink
I want some minerals so let's go ahead
and make sure you weren't going for a
whiskey sour
foreign
color but no
it's like Z radical
uh no not doing zerothical right now
either I've got my T and I add a splash
of minerals in there so I'm good I'm
doing keto and I'm staying on target
I've actually lost nine pounds since
last Sunday Dr Wallach so I'm very proud
of our keto 90 Kickstart program you're
the only person I've ever seen who looks
fabulous
who every day looks more fabulous
you are so sweet let's go to a break
everybody you
talk live
this program is sponsored by
askdoclive.com
and
we are excited to be able to bring this
information to you each and every day
if you are watching a replay of this
program make sure that you get back with
the person that shared it with it with
you or if you found it on your own you
can go to our website
askdoclive.com and click contact us and
we'll get you in contact with one of our
certified holistic health coaches that
can assist you in making sure that you
are getting exactly what you need to
reach your optimal health goals
if you were shared this program by
somebody specific I can't iterate it
enough get back with the person that
shared this program with you we are a
resource for a community of some amazing
people that have just a heart for others
in wanting to make sure that they're
getting the information that they can
personally use on a nutritional level to
create a better by the minute life we
will be right back on ass doc live
all right welcome back I I love how
we're able to gather together no matter
where we're at and get information and
communicate we have lots of questions
that have come in on the chat we've got
a couple hands up we will be getting to
the first hand as it is up as soon as Dr
Wallach gets back from his little break
and for those of you who are coming with
us
are here with us and if you have a
question please raise your virtual hand
go to the reactions in the zoom menu and
you will find that little button to push
that says raise hand and we will do our
very best to get through all of the
questions that have come in today
if you were invited by an email because
you're part of our newsletter subscriber
base feel free if you do not have a
youngevity associate that you are
working with or youngevity health coach
go ahead and do a reply to that email
one of our certified holistic health
coaches will get back with you please
note
I love technology especially when it
works and when your domain provider and
your email provider make changes and
then all the connections don't work we
have had a little bit of issue with our
emailing system but I think it's all
complete and everything is going through
and coming back to us as it should so if
you've submitted questions in the past
and you did not get a response we
greatly apologize for that but we do
have a team that are working on getting
responses to those emails from those who
are part of our subscriber base if you
would like to be part of our
subscription
um followers are asked live followers or
critical Health news followers please go
to
askdoclive.com or
criticalhealthnews.com and sign up for
our newsletter when you sign up you also
get an email with the Good Foods bad
foods list so that you can have right
there in print what are the bad foods
that you want to stay away from and what
are the good foods that you want to
increase in your daily diet so it starts
with that folks getting rid of the bad
foods increasing the good foods and
adding the 90 essential nutrients that
the body was made from and it's like gas
if you don't put gas in your car or oil
in your car
it's not going to continue to run at its
optimal best
that's how our bodies are as well so we
put a lot of stress on our bodies we
need to make sure that we are
treating ourselves with care and giving
it more than just calories because the
body's not deficient in calories in most
cases
it is deficient in nutrients so as soon
as Dr Wallach is back with us and I see
lots of hands popped up awesome we will
be getting
these questions so let me go ahead and
there he is
you are back well Dr Wallach let's go
ahead and go to the first hand that is
up okay we have Rob Rob go ahead and
unmute yourself if you want to come on
camera oh I see you don't have a camera
attached so I don't have my camera
attached sorry about that I've been busy
day oh Becca the hostess with the
mostess how are you today
thank you rob thank you okay
um doc I had a uh brief discussion with
uh Priscilla Presley her daughter Lisa
Marie passed away last night uh Cardiac
Arrest I'll have to speak to you in
private about that um okay later on or
talk to you and sharami about that
um I actually had a question
um for
um Rebecca as well too
um can you tell me the difference
between disease and dis ease which
Theory do you prefer to use with
youngevity products okay well we have
several actions here number one you want
to prevent diseases you want to promote
healthy growth and maintenance so you
want to prevent disease okay and then
also when somebody comes to you with
disease you want to support the body's
ability to maintain itself and then
repair
the the diseased tissues and replace the
dead tissues and so forth so you got two
or three or four things going on at the
same time and each thing
um has a different
um requirement
okay and so
that's why people say well why do you
have a nutritional program with 215
nutrients in it
well because the body needs a lot of
stuff to maintain itself and repair
itself and then we have as we've said
earlier in the in the program
we have these secret sauces
in addition to the 90 essential
nutrients which contain all the
nutrients we need to maintain ourselves
and grow and all that kind of stuff but
then if you have a disease say like
diabetes
we came up with an extra program okay
it's called sweeties which is the
specific nutrients that are missing when
you have diabetes there are no genetic
cases of diabetes diabetes is all a
nutritional deficiency and of course
that's why this book is it should be in
every family's household yeah okay yes
okay epigenous okay there are no jaguely
transmitted diseases if you have a
doctor who says oh you got a lot of
genetic disease in your family so we've
got to deal with that you have to excuse
yourself and find a different doctor
because the doctor is admitting he said
he's saying I know nothing here so I'm
going to blame it on your jeans okay and
so there are no jakely transmitted
diseases there are no
um diseases that are autoimmune where
your body's attacking itself you know
even things like lupus and rheumatoid
arthritis and irritable bowel syndrome
um if you if you ask Siri uh show me a
list of all the autoimmune diseases in
each organ system in the human body
you'll get a list of about
8 10 12 15 20 in each organ system
okay because everything that doctors
don't know they blame on autoimmune your
body is attacking itself that translates
in English to I have no earthly idea
what's going on here so I'm going to
blame you that way I don't have to plead
ignorance
yeah I just got a new medical doctor and
she's already giving me the speech of uh
high cholesterol and uh diabetes and all
that and uh have you heard have you got
it but Rob Rob you have to introduce her
to the science of crapola
doc we had quite the conversation with
our preliminary meeting already so she
has an idea I already mentioned you and
your history as well too and we're
working with uh I'm working with you and
Shar in that and uh so this is going to
be educational for her as well too so
that's an important thing we can educate
her and bring her along uh to where
she's up into the 21st century here
okay well you know me I'm trying to
change the Canadian medical uh you know
Health Care system so okay I'm gonna
stop there stop there for a minute Rob
Have you listened recently I want to
repeat that Have you listened recently
to the to the CD what kills billionaires
I have not heard that no okay now that
one was recorded in Canada
okay
okay there was 2 000 people at that
meeting
and half of them were Canadians and half
of them were Americans
and when you hear the audience
responding to my various statements and
everything you know when it came to
things that were they'd ask questions
about autoimmune diseases and genetic
disease and everything I tell them the
truth and it was not autoimmune not to
make it's just nutritional efficiency I
mean these audiences would freak out now
that CD is part of the trilogy that's in
the CD set there's a new Bull in town
okay dead athletes don't lie
um exercise on someone changes suicide
and then what kills billionaires and I
went back and I listened to it because
you know I hadn't listened to it in a
couple years and I went back and
listened to it and I'm saying oh my gosh
I should have been pushing this for the
last five years okay because it's very
very clear that um you know
relatively well educated and experienced
people in the Canadian and American
communities were just flabbergasted
getting the information now this was a
live presentation that I did in Canada
and in fact I Shar was in the audience
and I was asking her questions so she
was giving answers and Char of course as
a
high school graduate she knew more than
the medical doctors that were there in
that meeting
yeah she does she does she does yeah so
I I found the uh the the nine or ten
pounds that uh Becca lost so I'm gonna
have to work on that so yeah back I
found your weight I picked it up no I
didn't I didn't lose it Rob oh okay I
let it go I released it I found it
you were not supposed to find it I found
it I don't want it I want to get rid of
it no so I'm working on that so I'm
gonna have to uh yeah I'll get don't
forget your keto Shake don't forget our
keto Shake it's a mere pleaser yeah uh
working on how many meals a day Rebecca
how many meals a day do you recommend to
take the keto Shake
well it depends if you're doing our keto
90 Kickstart program and you're just
getting started we use intermittent
fasting also in that first three days
you are doing three liquid meals three
of them are a keto Shake one of them is
our keto hot chocolate which is
absolutely amazing and then using our
detox tea
um but once you get out of that first
three days then you're replacing
two
meals with a with a keto Shake
um you get closer to your goal you just
replace one okay I love the fact how
easy they are and they taste good yeah I
have to do some weight uh training now
too so well this helped me with building
muscle too
you know acids yeah I'm gonna throw
something in here here Rob if you
remember that exercise about
supplementation is suicide so don't just
think you're going to exercise that
weight off you need the keto shakes you
need the 90 essential nutrients get a
hold of that set you know there's a new
Bull in town you need the rebound okay
in addition to the health brain and
heart pack and the keto shakes I mean
losing weight could be dangerous
yeah we talked about this Dr Wallach
I'm in the method where I have to start
building muscle back in that too so I'm
working on that I'm on the 215 essential
nutrients plus so
um yeah I feel absolutely fantastic uh I
just have to uh get off my Christmas
weight now and continue with my healing
my neuropathy is basically gone away now
so your recommendation to increase my
selenium My ultimate selenium has been
working out fantastic
um so I'm at 210 right now so um yeah
I've got more than 10 to lose but are
you eating your three eggs twice a day I
ran out of eggs so I have to get more
eggs now so
um I'm trying to get backyard backyard
chicken so I can grow the ultimate
chicken eggs as well too well don't wait
until you do that you buy them from the
store yeah you can grow your own yeah
Becca you you were talking about a egg
substitute before I forget what that was
um so we have the I-26 hyper immune
powder right right that's it okay which
is which is made from organic non-GMO
eggs
um it's
it's a Powerhouse so that's something
um and that's another thing that Dr
Wallach and I have talked about is you
know when food shortages are happening
yeah this is something you definitely
want to be taking even before the foods
shortage happens I don't know why I
can't say that word but have it in your
storage so that you can continue to get
at minimum per dose 25 percent of the
recommended cholesterol and this is the
good cholesterol folks the stuff that
supports your brain the stuff that the
myelin sheath of your vagus nerves is
coated with created in your brain yeah
there's only one good cholesterol and we
say this we say this right on the label
Rob contains 25 of your daily
requirement of cholesterol you require
cholesterol makes up 25 of your brain
weight 25 of your spinal cord weight you
need cholesterol do not right okay do
not get again okay now I I only have two
big meals a day plus kind of a snacky
lunch my snacky lunch is a banana two or
three of those little baby Bell cheeses
and two of the chewable
i-26s no
okay I'm going to look into that great
thanks Becca thanks Doug uh um for Mike
wait now Doc uh how many MSM should I be
taking
I'm at 2 10 right now you should be
taking three three times a day as two
bottles a month okay great fantastic
fantastic okay thank you guys I
appreciate it good to hear from you
thanks Rob thanks let me just
let me share a little bit more about
that I-26 hyper immune doctor well like
because it comes any powder that you can
mix with water it reminds me of the
shell of like a cream puff or an eclair
it does not have a bad taste at all you
can also get it in capsules and then the
chewables come in two different flavors
so there's the vanilla and there's a
banana
um I like the vanilla and you do not
want to take it within two hours of
eating regular eggs so the antibodies in
in regular eggs that you would cook and
the antibodies that are in the I-26 you
don't want to confuse them so take them
totally separate from each other
okay let's go to Norma Dr Wallach Norma
go ahead and unmute
you're on live with Dr Wallach
hello Norman good morning Dr Walla I'm
glad to have the opportunity to be here
in
see you at least by soon I miss you all
on life where you live Norma
um I met you
um down here in Laguna Hills California
okay
uh-huh I had the opportunity to be there
and then yeah I remember how can we help
you today uh well I'm gonna try to make
sure my question
um I have a
um
a customer
he's being lately after this has
happened after Colvin after he had it
covered 14 months a month
I'm 14 months ago he
um recently he's been uh having
noison on his ear
but it's all day long
okay
all right
um let's see here let's see Rebecca
what's going on here if this guy's got
tinnitus ringing in the ears
well the tinnitus ring in the ears is
causing to an inflammation and also
osteoporosis of the skull that's
squeezing
that
yeah the eighth cranial nerve see I've
got it you've got me going in so many
different directions I haven't had the
chance to memorize each cranial nerve
and what they're for you
now you're doing very well and so how
old is this guy normally
um I'll put it in the chat I think as
he's hold on hold on give me one I have
it here so Dr Wallach
um he's 43 years old
170 pounds
he's one you want to ask how many times
he wakes up at night to urinate does he
wake up three times a night five times a
night ten times a night because you want
to find out if that skull is squeezing
the spinal cord okay and
um but when you have tonight is rain in
the ears all day and again can you show
that picture again uh Rebecca of the the
normal skull
yeah yep I got it right here okay the
normal skull is a quarter of an inch
thick the skull without osteoporosis and
is there you go inch and a half to two
inches thick and you can see where that
skull is two inches it can be squeezing
all those tunnels that the 12 pairs of
cranial nerves are going through and the
spinal cord is going through and that's
why he's got all these symptoms he's got
to thank you thank you okay and he
weighs how much you see
170 pounds okay so I want him to have
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no glutens no wheat nobody Ryan oats he
needs to be taking two Health abandoned
heart patch a month to follow those
running twice a day these two bottles of
the MSM so I take three breakfasts three
of them should live at dinner time it's
going to help rebuild
the bones cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between
vertebrate bone makes bone itself
including the bone marrow which produces
white blood cells and red blood cells
and platelets and antibodies and all
that kind of stuff and then he needs the
collagen peptides a scuba that with his
morning drinks with his evening drink
and I also want him to have the vitamin
D3 through even in California because
usually people who are a little older
they sit in the shade and watch the kids
play out in the sun okay so he needs to
be taking the vitamin D3 twice a day it
wouldn't hurt for him also to have the
synapto he could take three synaptic
twice a day that's two bottles a month I
do that it's you know in addition all
that
um I take about 75
tablets pills and capsules of secret
sauces twice a day in addition to all
this other stuff we've already mentioned
you know all they held the brain and
heart pack and and the uh rebound but I
also take all these secret sauces I mean
I probably take more nutrients per pound
of body weight than any other human
being on Earth okay and it pays off it
pays off and so
um that's my priority is to take as many
of these nutrients as I can and I have
witnesses okay
do you take that area I take all this
stuff every day I've been doing it for
you know uh first like 75 years how's
that work for you
let me repeat after everything yeah this
is recorded So if you have to you can
come back and listen to it again and
again and of course our telephone number
is toll-free so you can don't have to
pay for the call okay
okay thank you thank you Norma thank you
Dr Wella
all right thank you Norma and again for
everybody that is on this if you want to
watch the replay go to askdoc live.com
and you will find the replays of our
programs there since we started back in
July of 2020. wow
let's move right on Dr wallet because we
have several hands and questions let's
go to Pauline Pauline go ahead and
unmute yourself you are on live with Dr
Wallach
good morning Dr Wallace yes ma'am how
can we help you hey so my name is
Pauline uh there any person never been
over a hundred pounds and I'm 58 uh I'm
my height is four feet ten inches
and my concern has always been um
digestion I've also been diagnosed with
osteoporosis too
so
okay how many times a night do you wake
up to urinate once three times five
times
no I don't wake up okay good good
okay and then do you have joint pain do
you have pain in your knees and your
hips and your back and your neck and
my hands my fingers
okay
so you wouldn't call it pain you just
say you're aware of what's going on
correct okay do you have any high blood
pressure diabetes
no okay do you ever get sleepy an hour
after you eat dinner
we go to you know been watching TV with
your family and you fall asleep on the
couch
no okay good okay
um
like a set of taste is off you know it's
not the same
I'm sorry you say recently you have what
things must change now uh recently I
don't I guess bloating and um okay
digestion stuff okay
[Music]
okay so what I want you to do is get rid
of all the bad foods okay this this is
Paramount this is for everybody
everybody must get off the bad foods
even if you don't have any sicknesses
get off the bad foods then you won't get
the sicknesses okay no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no cell just you
know cooking oils absolutely no gluten
no wheat nobody ran oats no buckwheat
okay no sugar no carbonated drinks even
the diet one's got to go because
um the carbonation neutralizes stomach
acid so you cannot efficiently absorb
minerals and digest food Paramount okay
then as you say you're about a hundred
pounds is that correct
yes okay 100 pounds I'd have you take
healthy grain one healthy brand heart
pack per month take a half a dose of
everything twice a day get one bottle a
month of the MSM so you can take three
of breakfast three dinner time as you
take one scoop of the collagen peptides
at breakfast one scoop of the collagen
peptide at dinner time your drink
and then
um let's see here I also want you to
um I take the synaptive take three of
those twice a day those two bottles a
month okay so all your nerve connections
and everything are all that kind of
stuff is working
um
you can see here that oh and the
digestive stuff we have the ultimate
enzymes go ahead and take the ultimate
enzymes of your body weight you could
take one or two of those say five or ten
minutes for each meal with a couple
ounces of water that's going to help you
with your digestion but also getting rid
of all the bad foods is going to help
you with your digestion because uh your
intestines are supposed to look like a
shag rug the line of the intestines has
all those little finger like billi looks
like a shag rug when you're eating
gluten in buckwheat those finger like
projections go away and now instead of
looking like a shag rug your intestines
look like a plastic tube you've lost 98
of the your absorptive surface so all
this stuff that's going on in there that
shouldn't be going on in there because
you cannot absorb the food okay and so
that's what's going on and so give us a
call every two weeks because you're
going to have a good story and people
want to know hey you know what's going
on okay
what's going on with Pauline
all right okay sounds good let's hear
from you say in a week or 10 days or two
weeks but don't don't wait too long let
us hear from you so we can walk you
through this okay okay thank you that's
a lot you bet God bless
all right thank you Pauline and Dr
Wallach if I may add the essential Clary
Sage
essential oil Clary Sage has been shown
to help with calcium absorption I like
to add it to my CM cream
yeah so in the two ounce container
I'm gonna look it up and I'll post it or
let you know okay so rosellen is is
gonna make sure that we're getting the
right
um ratios as far as the Clary stages to
that two ounces of
CM cream so I also like to do I do four
drops of Clary Sage and my Epsom salts
and then I'll soak in an Epsom bath
because I had such bad osteoporosis of
the skull
and it's not the skull I mean it's
everywhere well yeah when you have
osteoporosis it's not just your shoulder
it's not just your hip it's not just
your skull when you have osteoporosis
and it's diagnosed in any bone and in
your index finger if you have actually
approaches diagnosing your energy finger
it's in every bone in your body you have
osteoporosis
so
that we can do to help support the body
and as
a digestion is Paramount and making sure
that you get a form of calcium like what
we have in the osteoporo FX product and
the Beyond tingy Tangerine product
with those essential cofactors that help
for the best optimal absorption possible
so that's correct
don't forget be prepared don't wait till
you're sick
that's where people make so many
mistakes well I'm okay I don't need to
do anything no this is the value here be
prepared that's the model of the Boy
Scouts okay be prepared prepared okay
and if you exercise which everybody
should I mean I I walk
close to three miles a day I take three
routes around the house a day One
backwards to make Rebecca happy because
she wants to do one backwards so that
I'm getting all my muscles
so I'm going right twice I'm going left
once kind of thing okay and so don't
forget what kills billionaires
if something can kill a billionaire they
can kill an average person
if you can prevent diseases as a
billionaire that same protection of a
billionaire can be used by you and me
okay so don't forget the CD what kills
billionaires is one of the three CDs in
this set there's a new Bull in town and
what what you know a great gift to give
somebody you love anytime there's a
present due we're talking about weddings
we're talking about births we're talking
about promotions we're talking about
having new babies we're talking about
birthdays we're talking about holidays
give this information give these
nutrients give them you know some
rebound do something that's going to be
a positive for them just taking them out
for dinner is kind of a nice social
thing but do that don't stop doing those
things but also give them something
that's going to add 25 to 50 healthy
years to your life
absolutely and Dr Wallach you gave me a
great idea
instead of just walking the opposite
direction
walk backwards
I'll have to put a a rear view mirror on
my way
yes
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it okay
Verna has a really good question in
regards to the Clary Sage she wants to
know if you can Spritz Clary Sage
mixture on the skin for absorption of
calcium and yes I love to mix colloidal
or colloidal minerals are plant-derived
minerals with essential oils and create
a grounding spray spray it on the bottom
of your feet
when you spray it on the bottom of your
feet your vessels are so close to the
surface
that it then gets into your bloodstream
quickly
and gets distributed now Ruth Ellen
share with us some more information
about Clary Sage okay so it there's
different dilution rates for different
people
so in a two ounce container if it's an
elderly person that's frail it's four to
eight drops
if it's children
um let's let's just go with
that doesn't make sense is it going by
weight or is it gone by health concerns
hope
so 12 drops would be for a normal person
so children on trail
okay so 12 drops of Clary stage and a
two ounce container of CM cream right
would be a good dilution for applying
this Clary Sage mixed with the CM cream
now with with other carriers including
the plant Drive minerals would it be the
same dilution yes because I'm going by
the dilution chart
okay so you've got a two ounce container
of plant Drive minerals and a little
spray bottle
you put in the 12 drops unless you are
working with or applying to somebody
that is elderly and frail and then it's
only four yeah so essential oils are
powerful and helping us to provide
additional support for the body but they
do not take the place of supplementation
through the 90 essential nutrients I
just want to make sure that there's lots
of clarity there
because there's a lot of alternative
modalities
um but folks were not alternative
modality deficient we're nutrient
deficient
and you can also rub it to the bottom of
the feet and it'll absorb in the body in
like three to four seconds
yeah let me tell you a little story
there if I may real quick
um
um remember that story about Pastor Mike
Freeman in Baltimore Maryland he was in
a coma for six months in a hospital and
the doctors notified his wife and Linda
Taylor one of our great Distributors up
there in Baltimore Maryland and said
look he's only got hours or days at the
most to live here this is after six
months he's at the end of a string and
so if you want to say goodbye to him and
with the possibility of him hearing it
you need to do it now and so she calls
me up and says um doc do we have
anything we can do for him I said well
yeah we need to get you know the
minerals into him does he have a G-tube
where he can just squirt this into a d
tube it'll go into him no they're
they're pulling his IV even you couldn't
even put in his IV because he's they're
pulling his IV because he only got hours
or a day or so left to live
okay so what I want you to do is get
arches our liquid plant minerals just
liquid metal not Cherry mints but to
liquid plant minerals
and put a half a cup a tea cup full on
the plant minerals on his back between
his shoulder plays in his lower back on
his chest and on his belly twice or
three times a day and using a cotton
ball okay
and then let's see we can do
well in three days time Pastor Mike
wakes up now remember he's been in a
coma for for six months
okay so he wakes up he shaves he goes to
his church
Studios where he has his TV station and
his um
a radio station and he tells the story
we have this the DVD and the CD he made
it's called Praise the Lord and Pastor
90 if you're in the military you know
what that means
praise the Lord and pass the ammunition
okay but in this case it's praise the
Lord in pension 90 and you know we have
a steady stream of people buying that
set the the DVD and the the CD because
this is something
that even just putting it on your skin
you absorb it
okay
and it's one of those things if you're
in a hurry and you know and oh gosh I
forgot to take it this morning in my my
supplements well just take it with you
and put it on your belly which is well
you're seeing at your desk working on
your computer okay and you'll absorb it
within minutes and of course that holds
true in our baby formula too okay it's
called kids toddy we have all the
nutrients in that except the efas you
gotta add the efas to it but the kids
taught it it can be a meal replacer or a
meal additive okay so we have all this
stuff in these liquid minerals but
praise the Lord and Pastor 90. I just
love that story Pastor Mike Freeman
yeah that's that is a great story Dr
Wallach and I do want to make sure that
people understand that it's not a meal
replacer it's a mil addition with the
kids toddy or any of the supplementation
because it doesn't have the protein and
the fats that the body needs that's
correct to be able to serve to sustain
life we get lots of food I mean lots of
carbohydrates opportunities of
carbohydrates which the body needs also
but it's those proteins and fats that
are going to allow the body to have lots
of energy and support muscle
let's go to Lisa Dr Wallach who has her
hand up Lisa go ahead and unmute
yourself you're on live with Dr Wallach
I'm glad you found that virtual hand yes
I finally found it
okay I am 62
five three and a half and about 101
pounds
and I got I got covered in October of
21.
and I'm okay but my body has not been
the same as it is in the sense of I feel
like I have inflammation
um I was getting the hair loss things
got better but it's still I don't feel
the same like I used to
um didn't take the vaccine I'm not into
vaccines first okay no no we had the flu
shot ever
okay do you have any other issues him
ringing your ears or balance problems
did you get a little hissing in my ears
and I've had that before
yeah it comes it comes in it goes
um I don't wake up at night to for to
urinate once in a great while I could
sleep but I I'm getting like tingling in
my bottom of my feet and I've had
swelling and I've been taking
um turmeric and that kind of helps
because then it you know it goes away so
I I don't take any vitamins right now
so here's here's the deal okay so you
say you weigh 101 pounds right yep okay
now you may have osteoporosis of the
skull
okay and
um we have the tingling in the feet it
could be simple sciatica or just a low
back problem or it could be osteoporosis
of the skull either one be the same
approach and so I do want you to get rid
of all the bad foods that's a that's uh
something that everybody has to do
everybody has to do it especially if you
don't have any problems Now's the Time
get off all the bad foods now don't wait
until you have a problem get off the bad
foods no bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no gluten so we
burn around notes no sugar no carbonate
or drinks even that one's got to go and
then at 101 pounds I want you to have
one healthy brain and heart pack per
month a half a dose everything twice a
day one bottle a month for the msmic
take three twice a day that's going to
help you rebuild cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
the vertebrae bone makes bone itself
including the bone marrow that's going
to support your immune system that's
going to support your uh your skull it's
going to support your disc between your
vertebrae all that kind of stuff all the
tendons and ligaments your body
then I also want you to take the
collagen peptides take two canisters a
month of that so you can take a scoop
with your morning drink and scoop your
evening drink and then you need the
vitamin D3 take three of those twice a
day those two bottles a month to absorb
stuff and put them all in the right
places and then
um I also want you to have our synaptive
anything that's going on with the the
cranial nerves and tinnitus said hissing
or ringing in the ears called tinnitus
is causing the squeezing the the
auditory branch of the eighth cranial
nerve okay and so you want to do that
and then don't forget to get a hold of
that book in the CD it's all in your
head and so you can show pictures of the
normal human skull and the human skull
when you have osteoporosis to the skull
and doctors know nothing about this you
can ask your doctor to laugh at you and
they'll say well where are you getting
that stupid stuff there's never been a
report about osteoporosis of the skull
because they always keep thinking of the
hips and the knees because they want to
do double knee Replacements double hip
replacements and amputate your legs and
give you artificial limbs and all this
kind of stuff
now you have to preach I'm going to
throw a figure at you here okay because
I've given you what I want you to take
but this figure is very important
now
um when it comes to how much money is
spent to deal with symptoms you deal
with the symptoms of arthritis and
osteoporosis in humans the United States
50 was a symptom not to prevent or cure
it you're talking about
three trillion dollars a year three
trillion dollars a year
626.8 billion dollars a year just to
treat the symptoms of joint obviously
poses which is called arthritis and then
you're talking about when you have
osteoporosis to treating the symptoms in
America in in adults okay you're talking
about 2.3 trillion so you had the
626.8 billion the 2.3 trillion you're
looking at three trillion dollars a year
we're spending treating the symptoms of
arthritis osteoporosis and adult humans
okay and that's why so many doctors want
to be orthopedic surgeons that's why so
many doctors want to be orthopedists
that's why so many doctors when they get
into general practice suddenly now they
all kind of Veer towards attracting as
many people as they can and have
um bone and joint problems because
that's where the money's at okay and we
can get rid of all those problems
because they're none of them are genetic
metamor autoimmune all of your joint and
Bone problems are
nutritional deficiencies there's no
autoimmune diseases even rheumatoid
arthritis is not an autoimmune disease
rheumatoid arthritis is very simple it's
an infection with a bug called
mycoplasma okay
um and on top of a nutritional
deficiency arthritis you take our
healthy Bone and Joint pack you take the
Minocycline which will kill the
mycoplasma and I don't care if you had
rheumatoid arthritis for 40 years
and give me 90 days and usually in less
than 90 days it'll be gone
okay it is is
um sometimes it's been this is being
blamed on like long hauler uh covet
could there be like protein stuck in
there I mean I didn't take any vaccines
didn't believe in yeah well see it
doesn't matter okay remember the doctors
are trying to explain what's happening
here in a way that they're going to you
have to go visit them for an office
visit and get a prescription and do all
this kind of stuff they're gaming the
situation
right
okay and so when you have something
they're calling long haul that usually
means you're nutritionally deficient and
you have all these things going on
and and just taking a painkiller will
give you some relief but this stuff
going on might get worse and worse and
worse and worse over time because you
haven't done anything with the nutrition
okay
all right yeah that well that was my
thing if this is going to help with with
that because I do eat pretty good I
don't eat any sugar
tell me tell me tell me tell me tell me
what does eat pretty good mean
um I'm not at the gold standard but I'm
not your average citizen I don't do
fried stuff I do butter and olive oil
um I'll eat organic I eat more chicken
mostly chicken some beef uh vegetables
and I stopped pop years ago I drink uh
bottled water or okay I would stop I
would stop the olive oil okay well you
know we do have the efas and Fa pluses
that are made in nitrogen
atmospheres so they don't oxidize when
you have the olive oil it could be the
best olive oil made for Kings but it
oxidizes and turns into trans fats which
causes cancer and produces inflammation
and all the tissues in the body
including the brain and so forth and and
you do want to eat three eggs twice a
day because you want your brain you want
your brain to work you want your spinal
cord to work right you want your
peripheral nerves to work two a day
two a day no that's not enough okay
okay follow us every couple of weeks
because you're gonna have a great story
okay great
thank you thank you thank you thanks
Thank you Lisa you
all right Dr Wallach I have at least two
questions that I want to get to in our
last 15 minutes of the show here so
Shantae has she's been working with a
mob she's got five little ones she's 35
years old five foot seven
130 pounds and losing weight
and she has
severe impaction Dr Wallach well here's
my constipation
yep severe constipation they have tried
the herbal rainforest which would did
not move it and she's now been diagnosed
with lupus
well there you go
yeah okay so the first thing she and
everybody in the household including the
dog and the cat and brothers and sisters
and kids and everybody
um so there's no cross-contamination in
the laundry the couches the beds the
rugs and so forth uh she's they got to
get rid of the gluten out of the house
no wait nobody Ryan oats no buckwheat
because that's what's killing your
intestines
um the gluten in buckwheat
um is what's killing the intestines and
causing her to be constipated got to get
rid of that got to get rid of the
cross-contamination okay
um if she doesn't want to be using
public washers and dryers if people in
the house are working in a kitchen
someplace and that and the other and
they're throwing their clothes in the
washer and dryer run
a uh a
um
just water yeah no we'll run we'll run
uh it's just an empty load just run an
empty load you know just don't put
anything in there just you know
run the run the laundromat in the house
once all the soap and everything like
that and get that cleaned out before she
puts her clothes in there okay and then
she needs to be taking everything we
just said
okay and then she needs to
be making sure that she avoids anything
that's going to interfere with
absorption no carbon or drinks she can
also have the rebound but the the herbal
rainforest uh if she's not getting any
benefit from that that means she's
getting contaminated so her intestines
are so damaged she cannot even absorb
herbal rainforest she got to be kidding
me okay so she's getting gluten and
buckwheat somewhere okay it's either
she's doing it herself or she's getting
cross-contaminated by her family or
workplace or something okay
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and the next one
um Carrie writes in and carry my my
thoughts and prayers are with you and
your mom so her mom is currently in a
Tennessee rehab center after a forced
heart attack she has very hardened
arteries she was air vacced for cardiac
center a little over a week ago or to
the cardiac center a little over a week
ago
um and now they will be advising statins
how can we reverse the clogging yeah
she's 78 years old she's a very high
energy driven person
five foot seven inches
220 pounds
okay five foot seven I'd like to see
your way maybe one for a lady maybe 160
okay so she might be 40 50 60 pounds
overweight so I want her to have one of
our keto shakes per a meal okay
um and this is not to add to a meal this
is a meal replacer it doesn't have to be
the same meal every day she needs two
Health abandoned heart packs per month
the football sitting twice a day she
needs the um two bottles a month in the
MSM she can take three of those twice a
day now the thing that's going to
support her blood pressure and support
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries in the brain the heart and the
kidneys and so forth and then don't
forget she needs a synaptic of three of
those twice so they have two bottles a
month I want to have three of the
um ultimate daily classic at breakfast
lunch and dinner it'll be three bottles
a month or small bottles I only have
three bottles a month of our ultimate
daily classic cows take three at
breakfast three at lunch feed dinner
time they're gonna support healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries and
healthy blood pressure she's on blood
pressure medication and do not cold
turkey off of it but as her blood
pressure begins to drop which it will
she can slowly reduce the medication
based on the numbers and I I always say
within 90 days it should be gone but
oftentimes we have people that haven't
urinated in in 10 years they're on
dialysis six days a week okay and in two
weeks time on that program uh they'll
start urinating so they drop the
dialysis down to three days a week and
then two more weeks are totally off a
dialysis after 25 years of being on
dialysis and 10 years of being totally
uh on six dialysis a day because they
couldn't urinate okay and so the body
has a remarkable ability to recover when
you give it what it needs and stop
beating it up with all the bad stuff and
again
you want to listen to that CD what kills
billionaires because this is the sort of
stuff that's in there that drove that
audience crazy in Canada half the
audience was Canadian half the audience
As Americans and I'm telling them these
things and this is like I don't know 10
12 years ago when that CD came out and
they were going crazy because they had
never heard of such a thing okay and of
course this is what really really
um made me put this CD in with the three
CD set there's a new Bull in town for
people who are uh athletes and dying and
just you know you have somebody like
um the daughter
of his famous singer Priscilla Presley
so Elvis and Marie Presley yeah daughter
of Elvis yes yeah she just died what 52.
54. 54 of a heart attack she died at 54
of a heart attack do you think she was
doing everything right no she was doing
everything wrong
and I guarantee you she had access to
the best doctors for giving her
medication but nobody was teaching her
how to eat properly and how to
supplement properly and so it was a lack
of supplementation and eating badly that
killed her
at age 52.
54. 54. okay
okay Dr Wallach let's go to one more
question that just popped up and Ida
would like to know is there a form of
tingy tangling Tangerine or similar
product that does not have vitamin K or
K2 she said the concern is for a friend
with cardio health issues and on
medications for blood pressure
okay well vitamin K2 and Vitamin K is
are essential nutrients okay
and so why she would not want to have
vitamin K
well it's because the pharmaceutical
says to avoid them Dr Wallach oh because
they don't want him to bleed to death
I'm assuming
Maybe
because you're probably giving her
anti-clotting and probably anti-clotting
drugs
that's probably what's going on there
and she needs to get advice from another
doctor but no we have vitamin K in just
about all of our multiples
yeah and then she did add on here the
concern was about blood clotting you're
so smart I don't know that I'm smart but
I've seen a lot of dead people when you
do 32 000 autopsies and you have all the
clinical records from all their lives
that come with that and some are
billionaires some are farmers some are
city folks some are athletes some are
academics uh some are kids some are
adults some are have gender issues some
are straight I I mean I've done
autopsies and every possible
community of people you can think of
Asians
whites blacks we're talking about
um
males females yeah
and so and this is all written up these
are all published and this is why my
thesis is in the Smithsonian Institute
in the Ashford treasure because they
showed that there were no there's no
genetically transmitted diseases there
are no genetically transmitted diseases
there's no autoimmune diseases and yet
doctors keep pushing that okay because
that's how they game the system
well Dr Wallach I love the fact that we
are able to
join forces and Empower people
folks yeah we can even join forces with
doctors if they're prepared to learn
something
absolutely well Dr Wallach you had
mentioned about you know bringing
doctors into the 21st century well I'm
bringing
Wellness Publications into the 21st
century
and something that I'm excited about and
I I was thinking about this when Rob was
on who was in Canada is
cost of postage to get anything in or
out of the United States is outrageous
so one of the things that we have to
look forward to that we're bringing to
the website are going to be digital
downloads of as many possible of the CDs
as we absolutely can we have a few books
that are e-books that will be available
for download as well and we will be
working on additional
downloadable options where people can
get information
instantly read it right there on their
mobile devices listen to it right there
on their mobile devices wherever you go
and just continue to feed your mind so
that you know how to feed your body with
information
to strengthen build up
and just be fabulous well Rebecca we
cannot thank you enough you're an angel
of God bringing us into the 21st century
can I thank you enough uh all your
knowledge and technology and your
passion because you can have this
technology and knowledge and if you
don't have the passion to help people
it'll be sitting on the shelf you know
in the library somewhere and you know
nobody have access to so we can't thank
you enough I know you work day and night
um to get this information out to people
and that's why I say you're an angel of
God and I know you're one of the one of
the
um
people who work with the health coaches
in such a way that when they you know
they want to get into the classes and
everything you're the one that helps
make sure that those classes are the
best or the best of the best and
everything's working the way it should I
know you're involved in that
you're one of the
um administrators
yep so I I'm actually the the student
Administration manager
so
I love being associated with that as
well and folks if you're interested in
becoming a certified holistic health
coach whether it's for your own
knowledge or to build a business get
back with or get with your health coach
or your youngevity associate ask them
about the program if they don't know the
program
even if you are somebody else's
distributor somebody else's customer you
can go to coachwith Becca
.com and get information about that
health coach certification course and
you remain the individual you remain the
customer the client the distributor or
whoever introduced you to youngevity but
it gives you that information for our
certified holistic health coach where
you can also enroll so I just want to
make sure people are aware of that
opportunity
that is available at coachwithbecca.com
um because it's an amazing program we
have people from all walks of life
around the world all different education
levels
speaking nothing but good things about
this course I mean I have a surgeon that
she's like I never learned any of this
in medical school Becca if I would have
known this it may have changed the
direction of my career path
because seeing people over she she was a
surgeon she was actually uh
breast cancer
that was her Focus she said when she
first started
in her
theater of surgery
people would come in with two or three
different Pharmaceuticals
when she retired she said they had
upwards of a dozen different
Pharmaceuticals that people were in and
as I have learned and everything has
just made sense through the program and
how it's taught with Dr wallach's
research to back it
she says I could have done even more
good for people in helping to prevent
them from having
such a high level of occurrence
when it came to this
folks
people really do
want information
but they don't know exactly where to
find it
so if you've ever been in a position or
want to
be part of this Crusade get with the
person that invited you to this program
respond to the email
and let's make sure that you're getting
in contact with somebody that can help
you reach your goals at building
healthier communities now what time is
it we got two minutes we got one hand
that came up Dr Wallach Steve
now I know Steve is one of our health
coaches so Steve do you have a question
for Dr Wallach yes hi Dr Wallach hi
Steve quickly a question for you about
what you might recommend for somebody
that has a herniated disc in his lower
back he's also in a lot of pain he takes
Advil for Relief he's 200 pounds and
he's 510. okay get rid of all the bad
stuff right notified no process me some
oils no glutens no wheat no buckwheat no
wheat Brown notes no sugar no carbonated
drinks and then two healthy brand hard
packs a month photo serving twice a day
two bottles a month of the MSM so you
can take three breakfast lunch and
dinner uh two canisters a month of the
collagen peptides a scoop of that and
breakfast school with that at dinner
time then let's see here vitamin D three
three of those twice a day
and then um let's see here
um
and for the pain of course you know we
have all the same creams and the uh
that's all the herbs that go along to
put in there and so forth and then
um I think that will do it the the disc
in the between the vertebrae respond
very quickly and it wouldn't hurt to ask
them
um it's a he right yes yeah ask him if
how many times a night he wakes up to
urinate once three times five times ten
times and see if he has obviously
approaches a skull because when you have
something going on in your low back and
your legs and so forth the odds are is
going on upstairs in the skull too okay
gotcha thank you very much appreciate
that well God bless you and thank you
for your good work thank you God bless
you appreciate it Dr well
all right thank you Steve and as my
co-hosts come on screen with us we just
want to thank all of you for joining us
here on askdoc Day live man I was I knew
I was gonna get it wrong
we're gonna stock live which has been
brought to you every Friday for two and
a half years
um that I have been the hostess of and I
will get it right Dr Wallach but on
behalf of myself and our co-hosts nasima
Omar Dr Judy Reynolds Heather Bowen Ruth
Ellen Sanchez and our Digital Media
Master John T mccollier we
thank you for becoming empowered we're
taking on what you can do yourself
at creating healthier communities Dr
Wallach thank you again for spending
time with us we greatly appreciate you
and all the work that you have done over
the last
75 years because we're going back to
when you were nine okay but everybody
have a wonderful wonderful week we'll
see you next week and
new Time new place so thankful that we
had not new time but new place new
address so thankful that we had a
lot of people find us so
have a great one everyone bye for now
bye-bye thank you so much Becca thank
you team love you guys
oh my God thank you Dr Wallach all my
health hostesses
yes
bye for now everybody bye-bye